geronimi
pronostics snh d'argent devant une carte
de l'ukraine presqu'île maculé volodymyr
zelensky se tient debout à côté d'un
drapeau ukrainien
il s'adresse aux russes mongol date je
te méprise à ce match digne maraude au
crâne dont 15 quines à rome où 10 des
mots forts prononcé quelques heures
avant le début de ce qui se voulait une
opération militaire russe dans le
donbass et qui a mené des troupes
jusqu'à la capitale kiev 1
les ukrainiens se remémorent leur passé
et construisent leur propre destin
poursuit-il ils bâtissent leur avenir
contrairement à ce qu'on vous dit chaque
jour à la télévision vachement bastia
le ton grave zelensky appelle le peuple
voisin dénoncer la guerre menée par le
président poutine depuis ce discours
l'ancienne vedette de la télévision
devenu président de l'ukraine s'est
forgé une stature politique celle d'un
dirigeant fort au sang froid dans cette
crise on a besoin de l'image d'un dans
les heurts de la nation et c'est vadimir
et lens qui a su incarner cette image
aux yeux des ukrainiens qui n'ont pas
forcément voté pour lui au départ
volodymyr zelensky avait créé la
surprise en annonçant fin 2018 sa
candidature au poste de président il a
mené campagne contre la corruption et
pour la paix dans don basse et récolté
73 % des votes j'ai grandement
apprécié depuis l'invasion russe il a
troqué son costume cravate pour des
tenues de couleur kaki la couleur
militaire jimdo bridge et dans les rues
de kiev ils multiplient les appels à la
mobilisation depuis son téléphone pour
tenir bon les troupes ukrainienne et les
citoyens ukrainiens les 6/10 l'ukrainien
qui sont concernées par le conflit ils
ont vraiment besoin d'avoir le discours
qui leur est adressée de l'avoir d'une
manière régulière saisissant toutes les
tribunes qui lui sont offertes actifs
sur les réseaux sociaux le président
ukrainien se transforme en chef de
guerre alors que vladimir poutine campe
dans une image conventionnel c'est
l'opposition on peut entre quelqu'un qui
vient du monde
de du kgb avec le passé lourd soviétique
puis quelqu'un qui vient du monde des
médias et de la communication est
effectivement zelensky fait preuve d'une
muse âge très
moderne des technologies c'est un peu
comme le contraste entre la modernité et
la tradition
en se révélant de la sorte le président
ukrainien a suscité une adhésion qui
dépasse les frontières des
manifestations en mai millions russie on
est en train d'une certaine façon de
déconnecter la population russe de
l'effort de guerre de poutine ce qui
n'est jamais une bonne chose ça semblait
une offensive personnel de poutine en
ukraine est ce ça fait une grosse
différence après cinq jours
d'affrontements volodymyr zielinski est
toujours en ukraine aux côtés des
citoyens qu'ils continuent de se battre
jusqu'au bout et sur une base plus
singulières la guerre des communications
qu'il mène contre vladimir poutine
semble tourner à son avantage ici s
mitraillette radio canada montréal